[Music]
no I did when I mention something I've
been talking a lot about New York and
how much I miss New York and I really
this week I want to celebrate some of
the amazing great things about New York
City that I do not take for granted one
of the most amazing things is that you
can pick up the phone and get Chinese
food in this town delivered to you in
five minutes
Anytime Anywhere that doesn't happen
anywhere else in the world
the other day the other day I thought
it'd be kind of fun and interesting and
educational to go to work as a Chinese
food delivery guy just to see what it's
like take a look okay well I will
deliver and then deliver this place is
hoppin is my friends that's Charlie
that's Shawn that's Patrick Seamus okay
I'm gonna go to the counter I'm gonna
wait for you to give me the delivery and
then I gotta go okay okay calm down okay
you were it you just don't stop do you
you don't go go go go
these two aren't working they're goofing
off guess this is king Juan what does he
would like what's that I don't know do
we have we have rice what's your name
I'm Conan O'Brien yes yes I gotta go I
got a delivery I'm gonna hang up on you
and your orders not being placed
[Applause]
Hudson let's do it let's do it
maker high-five me me
Hey good to see ya I'm looking for
Hudson where's Hudson Street [ __ ] off
this way
got it I see 3:15 I'm delivering Chinese
food
this is 3:15 Hudson this food is hot I
got to get it to her when she knows it's
me she's gonna be fine trust me I've got
away with people especially the ladies
can I give that to you
it's 1565 I'm the delivery guy
[Applause]
this Chinese food you want that it's
really good it's your king wat okay
[Applause]
that went very badly the woman refused
to take the food refused to speak to me
and then someone else threw coffee at me
I guess it's welcome back to New York we
ran it we ran into a little bit of a
problem slight glitch with the office
building yes West Broadway West Broadway
Broadway this way
there's a few less crunchy things hi
come on I'm looking for West Broadway
you were very beautiful I was living
food but I met you and everything's
changed
it's like an argent on green tea you
want some
you're like a dream what are the middle
three ok the middle straw yeah is this
marijuana
[Applause]
the Argentine coffee
yeah is fantastic well very nice to meet
you
need to be with you
this way the numbers ago on the runway
he was something in that team
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
hey yes ups you want some soup here's
your spoon alright enjoy that food let's
go this way hey you guys want some
spareribs those theorems are few cuz the
bags getting too heavy so I'm just gonna
give you those alright okay so a problem
I give giving away most of the Chinese
food I can't find a Chinese restaurant
but I found this Thai restaurant just
get me your soups get me three of your
soups and whatever you think is good I
don't I just I just don't want to be in
trouble there's music playing right now
behind me that's completely unclear
about too expensive some curious to see
what kind of music they end up putting
behind me because it's a very famous
song by Michael Jackson it would thrill
you to hear
so much thank you very much
[Music]
hello hi
now hold on and Colonel Brian in person
what's wrong with me on TV replace it so
I got Thai soup instead
which costs more and we can are you from
Thailand
I got you soup from Thailand I just want
to say it was an absolute delight
meeting you ladies you ladies took a bad
day and he made it fantastic and I
believe you're what's best about New
York City
[Applause]